this week's episode is brought to you in
part by ops Genie incidents happen
thankfully ops genie empowers dev and
ops teams to plan for service
disruptions and stay in control during
incidents
it also gives teams the power to respond
quickly and efficiently to unplanned
issues and helps to notify all the right
people through a smart combination of
scheduling and escalation paths with ops
Genie your next incident doesn't stand a
chance
visit ops Genie comm to sign up to get a
free company account and add up to five
team members that's ops Genie comm never
miss a critical alert again with ops
genie
welcome to the science podcast for
December 14 2018 I'm Megan Cantwell on
this week's show I talk with Tina
d'amour and Brett Fishman about their
contemporary take on Garrett hardens
1968 paper tragedy of the Commons
how does hardens paper hold up fifty
years later I also speak with Simon
Fischer about the link between
Neanderthal genes and less globular
heads in living Cubans this week marks
the 50th anniversary of a hallmark paper
published in science tragedy of the
Commons where ecologist Garrett Hardin
questioned society's ability to manage
shared resources using a communal piece
of land or Commons as an example he made
the argument that because people are
motivated by self-interest the land
would eventually be overused and
destroyed he concluded that government
control and intervention through
sanctions or penalties were solutions to
this problem and would prevent the free
rider dilemma those benefiting from
resources without any payment since 1968
many have challenged Hardin's
conclusions notably Elinor Ostrom who
won a Nobel Prize in 2009 for her
analysis on Commons governance she
contended that communities could in fact
manage their own resources without
oversight by central authorities and
outline principles for how Commons could
be successful I spoke with two of the
authors from a Policy Forum and this
week's issue of science entitled tragedy
of the Commons revisited to see if
operating and Commons really is so
tragic first for a historical update on
Hardin's take we have Tina d'amour who
is a professor of social and economic
history at the University attract a teen
a high in Hardin's tragedy of the
Commons what did the Commons refer to
and why did it lead to problems in his
opinion well he actually referred to
what could be described as a sort of
early modern maybe even medieval pasture
land whereby a lot of cattle was grazing
and basically the farmers were using it
to graze our cattle and you didn't
really have according to Hardin at least
a lot of rules or a lot of consensus
about how to use that common and in his
article he actually assumes that when
people use resources collectively then
tragedy will follow did Commons in early
modern agriculture actually face these
challenges from your research they went
to lots of difficult periods in history
with environmental political economic
shocks etc but what is quite striking is
that regardless of these these crises
the Commons of which we still have quite
a lot of documents left they did a
pretty good job in surviving even if
they have to work together then they
find ways to solve the problems they
were facing as a collectivity Pardons
argument suggested that the solution to
these problems could be property rights
or government leviathans were these
common in these early Commons you can't
really speak of property as such as we
know it today yet in that period you can
only do that from the early 19th century
onwards basically callers were farmers
that at some point is covered that if
they would use our pasture land together
it would actually be more efficient to
do so so then they went as a group of
farmers collectively to the local Lord
and said we want to do this differently
and we want to set up an arrangement
whereby we as commoners as local farmers
have the right to exploit this according
to the rules we set ourselves but they
were actually managing the land by
themselves the rules they made to make
sure that the group of people could work
together in a proper way
and do so in a resilient way and these
document the survival of Commons for
hundreds of years six seven hundred
years is not an exception of those
documents that you evaluated what did
you find were the qualities that
promoted resilience and success within a
historical Commons we came up with
several conclusions that we're still
continuing to work on those data one of
them for example is that the graduated
sanctioning that Lynn Ostrom describes
as being so important is hardly ever
found in all the comments we study
we actually think that the variation and
the local embeddedness of different
types of enough sanctioning is far more
important than this particular type of
sanctioning graduated sanctioning the
other thing we also find is that maybe
we're overall overestimating the role of
sanctioning in the prevention of
free-writing
in fact if we compare the longevity of
the commons in our study or we look at
comments surviving from two to six seven
hundred years and we compare this to the
intensity of the sanctioning that they
came up with now we find that there's
actually a sort of negative correlation
between the two so the comments that
survived the longest were those that
actually invested the least and coming
up with sanctions as a way to prevent
free-writing
so commons that lived longer didn't
necessarily invest a lot of time in
inventing sanctions what would you say
is the insight that this historical
perspective can give to how land
management is carried out in this day
and age I think this has several
implications on the one hand when it
comes out to land management we learn
that land can be managed in a
sustainable a resilient way by commoners
themselves and without overusing it as
long as they're sufficiently involved in
the process and they're aware of the
limits that the resources have I think
that that's the other issues well here
that with today we see a huge
development in Commons especially for
example in Europe Commons is a real
buzzword and I think what would it can
really do to society in a positive way
is to help people realize again what the
limits are of the resources they work
with thanks Jenny now we have Brett
Frischmann a professor in law Business
and Economics at Villanova University to
talk about a different kind of Commons
the knowledge Commons hey Brett hey
there thanks for having me how does the
concept of tragedy of Commons apply to
something a little more abstract like
knowledge in the context of knowledge or
data or information there's a verb
the tragedy of the Commons that's called
the free rider dilemma so the free rider
dilemma is this concern that it's not
about overuse of the resource depleting
the resource but if you think about what
happens when ideas are made or
information or data is made openly
accessible free for all to use that
presents a risk sometimes to investors
that a second comer or third comer or
someone else will be able to use it
cheaply without having to contribute to
the investment that was made to produce
in the first place and so there's this
concern that that will lead to a dilemma
we'll have the under production of
things that we might want to see which
is quite different from the conventional
tragedy of the Commons where you've got
a pasture or a lake or an irrigation
system you have it already but you're
worrying about it becoming depleted it's
more like you're worried about it not
being produced further because people
aren't incentivized to keep creating it
so your piece is centered specifically
around something that you refer to as
the knowledge Commons could you give an
example of what falls under this
category so we use the word knowledge
broadly to encompass all kinds of
products of human intellect ranging from
data to scientific research to even
patented inventions and the idea of of a
knowledge Commons is where you've got a
collection of those kinds of resources
brought together within a community and
sort of produced and sustained and
sometimes curated by the community
itself we've had things as varied as
genomic data pools collected together to
rare disease research consortium sort of
consortium of clinical researchers
distributed around the country working
at hospitals and who have patients with
rare diseases and they're sort of
collecting their data and pulling it
together so there's there's lots and
lots of different examples the
interesting thing about knowledge
Commons is we tend to take them for
granted because they're so frequent
they're part of the way we communicate
and share our experiences socially more
generally from those case studies that
you've looked into what are things that
they have in common in terms of hurdles
that they face
more that we look at these case studies
we realize that groups that come
together with the purpose of generating
and pooling and sharing knowledge
resources they do confront free-rider
problems they do confront some of these
tragedies the common style problems but
there's also a whole bunch of other
dilemmas that they simultaneously have
to overcome in order to be successful as
a knowledge Commons so if I use the rare
disease research example that I
mentioned before the researchers are
spread all around the country doing
other things besides clinical research
on that particular disease and so if you
can reduce the cost for them to
collaborate that's not really a free
rider problem that but it's a sort of
structuring problem other dilemmas that
they face sometimes have to do with sort
of more conventional cooperation
problems where just getting people who
are different from each other who are
coming from different backgrounds and
have different sets of interests to be
able to see a joint purpose there's an
array of different dilemmas that these
communities face in order for them to be
successful in achieving their objectives
overall do you think there is a way to
promote the sharing and curating of
these intellectual and cultural
resources one step to sort of figuring
out how to be successful with knowledge
Commons is to study knowledge Commons
systematically and see what works and
what doesn't work across different
groups and from there you learn lots of
interesting things I mean one of the
things we started to see in a bunch of
our case studies is how important is to
invest in the infrastructure for
knowledge production within these groups
so oftentimes it's sort of a shared set
of standardized protocols that enable
researchers to collect data in a
standardized fashion so it can be
contributed to a pool right that sort of
underlying basic infrastructures is
quite important to success thank you so
much Bret no you're welcome it's been a
pleasure special thanks to editor bread
Weibull for soliciting these
perspectives within the policy for him
you can find a link to the entire peace
tragedy of the commons revisited at
science mag slash podcasts stay tuned
for my interview with Simon Fisher on
why some humans have less globular heads
than others
[Music]
this episode is brought to you in part
by ops Genie incidents happen and they
require complex coordination between
operations and software development
teams who are putting out fires every
day that's why getting alerts
immediately is critical thankfully
there's ops unit by Atlassian ops Genie
and powers dev and ops teams to plan for
service disruptions and stay in control
during incidents
it also gives teams the power to respond
quickly and efficiently to unplanned
issues and helps to notify all the right
people through a smart combination of
scheduling an escalation past an account
for things like time zones and holidays
better yet opportunity allows for deep
flexibility and how when and where
alerts are deployed with over 200
integrations like JIRA Amazon CloudWatch
data dog New Relic and more plus
attracts all activity and provides
useful insights to improve future
incident responses with ops Genie your
next incident doesn't stand a chance
visit ops Unicom to sign up to get a
free company account and add up to five
team members that's ops Genie comm never
miss a critical alert again with ops
genie
I'm here with Simon Fisher to talk about
why me and atolls had elongated skulls
and what that can tell us about head
shape in living people hey Simon hi so
what exactly are the differences between
the Neanderthal skull and human skulls
so one of the most distinctive features
of the human brain and the human skull
is this globular shape so a bit like a
basketball
whereas Neanderthal skulls have a quite
elongated shape which is very different
and how did you determine how globular
the heads are within living humans is
there a spectrum of more globular versus
less globular we started by taking
fossil skulls of Neanderthals and of
anatomically modern humans and we used
morphometric techniques to compare the
shape between these different skull
types and what we were able to show then
was a metric that distinguished between
the Neanderthal brains and the human
brains and what we found was that there
was a range of variation within humans
of the same population but nobody
importantly nobody is shaped like a like
a Neanderthal there's still a very clear
distinction between a human brain shape
and in yonder cells what did your team
uncover was the driver of that
difference we wanted to know what
genetic factors might be important for
leading to this variation in brain shape
within our different healthy human
adult's and what you can do is take DNA
samples from people and then you could
scan across the genome so look for DNA
variants that people might carry that
might affect how globular their brain is
now we only had about 4,500 people that
we could do this and we know that
effects on human brain anatomy in living
humans are subtle so we know that any
individual genetic effect would be very
small on
on the shape of the brain so we didn't
want to do a unlimited search through
the genome because we know that for
effects that are subtle and we would
need many thousands tens of thousands of
people maybe hundreds of thousands of
people we wanted to have a hypothesis
about which variants in the genome might
be the most important ones to look at
for this we took advantage of the fact
that living humans carry buried in their
genomes fragments of Neanderthal DNA so
we thought we should target these
Neanderthal fragments and people test
than the undertale fragments that we
could see and we were asking a specific
question which is if you carry a
Neanderthal fragment of DNA does that
push your brain away from globule arity
in a very subtle way and we tested each
of these fragment tested a few thousand
fragments across the genome and we came
across a couple of fragments that were
pushing people's brains just that little
bit towards an elongated shape and then
we could ask what were the genes that
were contained in these fragments and
could we find out anything interesting
about Biot the biology of this
difference from studying those fragments
yeah so the near that all alleles that
you discovered that influence the
expression of these genes well what
exactly do the individual gene variants
control one of these genes a gene called
called UBR 4 is important for the ways
that neurons divide and the way that
they proliferate in the developing brain
and we know that because when a mouse
lacks this gene it leads to a
microcephaly leads to a smaller brain
and what we found here was that of
course people carrying the Neanderthal
version of this gene it's not that the
gene is inactivated but we found that
the gene was less active in part of
their basal ganglia and that's
interesting because that's exactly the
kind of difference that might need to
changes in the shape of the brain the
other gene that we identified is also
very interesting and this is a gene
called flip one and this gene seems to
be important in myelination so in the
development of the app
myelin sheath that goes around axons
that can influence how well connected
different brain regions are to each
other and we found in this case that
this gene was slightly more active so
this over activity would be correlated
with a kind of less minor nation for the
cerebellum and maybe less connectivity
and again the cerebellum is this
structure at the base of the brain that
seems to have changed quite a lot in
recent evolution changes in those kind
of structures might ask you to visibly
need two changes in brain shape but
again to emphasize we think that this
trait this globule arity is influenced
by many different genes and the effects
of these individual fragments are small
so we think there's much many more
things that we're all we could hope to
discover by by looking at this kind of
trait and the nice thing about the this
first study is it shows how we can get
clues to the biological pathways that
might help to drive differences
wrenching so you found that the presence
of these Neanderthal alleles lead to a
reduced roundness in the head but could
it also have any kind of behavioral
implications one of the things that we
don't yet know is how differences in
brain shape in popularity connect might
connect to behavior and cognition we
actually don't know anything about that
at this point that's something that we'd
like to find out by studying more larger
samples and studying more phenotypes or
more traits in relation to this you
worked with a limited data set but
within that data set was it more common
for Europeans to possess this gene
variant or not because these fragments
are rare it's only a small percentage of
people within this big sample he would
carry each particular Neanderthal
fragment the people who carry these
Neanderthal fragments the particular
ones that we've associated in this study
those people that wouldn't look any
different from if you saw them on the
street there they're completely within
the normal range of variation and it's a
subtle effect why do you think it's
important to learn how Neanderthal DNA
influences living people what I like
about what we what we're doing here
that way we have a really tractable
difference in anatomy that's so
distinctive and we know they evolved
quite late you know that three hundred
thousand years ago our brains were
elongated and a hundred to 50,000 years
ago they were they were much more
globular so that's what what's really
attractive here is that we have a we
have a good handle on this very clear
difference that we don't have debate
about and we're trying to understand
what that could mean for the brain and
what that could mean for human evolution
I don't necessarily think that
Neanderthal biology by itself is is the
goal of what we're doing what's really
intriguing is that we can use those
fragments as a kind of window into the
biology of ourselves what is the next
step with this research what we'd like
to do next is to take advantage of these
really big datasets like the UK biobank
where you could we could potentially
look at tens of thousands of brains and
what we could then do is do a kind of
unbiased scan across the entire genome
looking beyond Neanderthal each breast
regions and try and see how much of this
the variability and globule arity we can
we can explain asking about the
different biological pathways and we
might be able to ask other questions
about evolution that we haven't been
able to answer yet thank you so much
Simon okie Simon Fisher is a mere
geneticist and director at Max Planck
Institute for psycholinguistics
you can find a link to his research at
science mag slash podcasts just a
reminder this episode has been brought
to you in part by ops Genie incidents
happen thankfully ops genie empowers
devs and Ops teams to plan for service
interruptions so plan for service
disruptions and stay in control during
incidents it also gives teams the power
to respond quickly and efficiently to
unplanned issues and helps to notify all
the right people through a smart
combination of scheduling and escalation
paths without uni your next incident
doesn't stand a chance
visit ops Unicom to sign up to get a
free company account and add up to five
team members that's ops genie calm o-p-s
GE n IE comm never miss a critical alert
again with ops genie and that concludes
this edition of the science podcast if
you have any comments or suggestions for
the show write to us at science podcast
at AAAS 0 RG you can subscribe to the
show anywhere you get your podcasts or
we can listen on the science website
that's science mag
podcasts to place an ad on the science
podcast contact mid-roll calm this show
is produced by Meghan Cantwell and
edited by potta G Jeffrey Cooke composed
the music on behalf of science magazine
and its publisher triple-a s thanks for
joining us